the number of new coronavirus cases is
falling in america but in europe it has
jumped more than 50 percent in the past
month alone charlie dagetta spoke to a
key official who is ringing alarm bells
don't like the sound of that charlie
good morning
good morning tony kovitt has been
resurging even in places where they
thought they had it nailed down and we
were told success today does not mean
success tomorrow and america should pay
attention
[Music]
europe is again under siege and racking
up record case numbers
and that is a grave concern warns the
head of the world health organization
europe and if you look at the last four
weeks the hospitalization has doubled
hans kluger says vaccination uptake has
plateaued in parts of europe at the same
time there's a relaxation of the public
health
and social measures which is a cocktail
for what we see of fort wayne and he
calls his region the epicenter of a new
global outbreak fueled by the delta
variant
european countries with higher
vaccination uptake appear to be holding
coveted bay while in some eastern
european nations the daily mortality
rate is surging for example portugal has
one of the highest vaccination rates in
the world yet romania has one of the
lowest in europe and one of the highest
death rates on the globe and just today
germany's infection rate reached the
highest recorded level since the
pandemic began vaccines are a game
changer but is not enough we need to
keep pressure on the virus not
surrendering on masks
the hand washing indoor ventilation
particularly in the schools
schools are being blamed for rising case
numbers in the uk prompting fears that
another lockdown may be looming i think
they can see it coming but it's that
fine line between letting people go
about their daily lives and also trying
to keep people safe
should americans be paying close
attention to the situation in europe and
taking lessons away from that absolutely
the basic principle is
if there's a situation
where
the peak is accelerating
don't
wait
the earlier the stricter the better
now we asked what this means with
thanksgiving and christmas coming up he
said celebrate safely keep the numbers
down and in his words vaccinate and
ventilate
tony oh
advice charlie dagetta in london for us
charlie thank you very much